now for for our next game okay only be
protected and democracy thrives the core
interests of reading the elections your
election sections and favorite social
media giant invite those everything
about you and their main getting an
order need to tailor your opinion to
their interests as they are fooling you
into voting for their pumpkin
congressman for us in fact we have the
single most powerful population control
tool ever created defend democracy help
us tear down in fact this your process
narrow that down the way our happen
together the blue explores Carla Smith
Russ join us we are tensed
hello everyone and then welcome into the
San Francisco Bay Area the birthplace of
the tech revolution and watched our
students new playground this time you
will join that sec a hacker group
rebelling against an establishment that
uses technology to take away our freedom
you are mark your solloway a brilliant
young actor on a mission to take back
control from this establishment now we
all live in the hyper connected world
everything we use and every one of us is
connected to technology from the
perspective of the hacker this world is
filled with opportunities so in watch
sucks to everything around you can be
act and creative way
you can also profile manipulate and act
everyone and you're not alone
you can seamlessly encounter other
dead-set actors and now getting into
coop is never been simpler but for now
let's deal with invite a social media
giant that's just been exposed by that
second
a little bit of light and we'll deliver
our fake sister sure are you a good
obviously gives its apartment okay
people this is strictly by the book
then paint outside the lines and stay
frosty the Bay Area is filled with
stories you can choose to explore but
Janelle is just Jack what happens when
ten seconds will create a politician
standouts the fun of an instant invite
might have helped to rig the election
Oh Kevin [ __ ] live over there
Oh check it out you can see the whole
city from here a lot of people out there
man
a lot of people yeah
kidding screw
no even feel it just know
this [ __ ] up
I know it's gonna be a hell of a fight
turning them back into people
[ __ ] any man okay do you find the
events and I'm on our exit strategy
hey is that the congressman I know I do
believe that is a hugger [ __ ] you
Marcus the building just went off the
grid we can't get in or see inside
they're up to something
I'll see what
they got armed helping there something's
definitely up
ah keep there's firming evidence get us
access Marcus before it all gets white
I'll get you inside the system once I do
you use the button that the brute force
your way in and download everything you
can but once you start downloading
they'll know you're inside I wouldn't be
a party if they didn't and I got a
surprise for
where are we on live in Congress and
cloud that's done there be anybody
starving about us to better good it is
the best computer forensics team we have
paved our town that's what I wanna hear
rich realizing
yo Satara I'm ready to go in play me
something fresh
don't sweat the technique
ow
and it's not now there's something over
there
I think Mason
I drop the basically
big traces for a cake sweet sweet sweat
to tell me I made my mess biggest beach
parties club oh geez on the ground hello
guys you're all they're already gone
this isn't our first rodeo
my boys in here
have to reach asleep and beat the
technique
you're in if you think
you're only making things worse with me
remember the light a fire
hey color your insanity
and you're no
holy [ __ ] this is awesome butyou're dies
later now if you're just getting started
so great watchdogs too comes out on
November 15 2016 on ps4 Xbox one and PC
it's so cool to see my hometown in that
game and much like you whenever I am
infiltrating a corrupt politicians
penthouse I also listen to Eric B and
Rakim and now